okay so let's get down to the business
end where we are going to face the main
line of the colorado gambit which start
after move bishop to b5
and here i recommend that you should
certainly capture this pawn and after
knight to e5 we should play queen to d6
and we already know what you should do
after queen to e2 so the main line runs
with the move d4
and here i recommend that you should
play knight to f6 and this is pretty
much the starting position of the main
line
now if you can see i have highlighted by
the arrows over here white has few good
options
but before we go and look at those
options let me tell you something
from last one year or so i am trying
colorado gambit against different rated
players
and
even earlier i was a bit scared of the
main line but from my heavy research
from the last six months
i am now confident enough to play this
line against anybody
there are a few things you should note
before we continue
black king will remain in the center for
a while but
fight cannot exploit this and
meanwhile black can create certain kind
of imbalance which will confuse the
whole wide setup
the amount of complexity exists in this
line it's even
very complex for the higher level up to
iem or gm level and that's why it's very
unlikely that your opponent is going to
churn out let's say 10 15 moves of the
computer in today's world where most of
the chess are playing with the clock you
can also get heavy benefit of the time
margin
so considering all this let's get
started so the first move which i want
to consider castle
and here i recommend that you should
play immediately knight to d7 so idea is
very simple black one to capture this
knight and
according to this thread
white has the only two good reply which
are the f4 and bishop to f4 so let's see
each by turn so first move i want to
consider is bishop to f4 afterwards
black has to capture this knight with
the c knight and here again white has
two choices if bishop captures e5 then
black is going to play queen to b6
attacking the bishop and wide response
is ready for pretty much force in one of
my game my opponent decided to play
knight to c3 but after very simple c6
the resulting position is very much
favorable to the black the further game
goes like this so my opponent plays
bishop to d3 but after captures captures
and
again captures captures i played the
move g6
and after knight to a4 attacking my
queen i simply attack his knight
and after b3 i played bishop to g7
attacking e5 and my upon responded with
the move f4 where i responded with the
move e6 and here my opponent responded
with queen to e3 so his threat is very
simple he wants to play knight to c5 but
it's time to pause over here what black
his achieve is
black has managed to
exchange his bad bishop and put his all
pawns on the light square and black has
this wonderful dark square bishop as you
will see as the game goes on this will
become more and more
plus position for the black so here i
want to stop knight to c5 with any sort
of concession so i drop my bishop back
to f8 and here my opponent attacked my
queen with the move a3 i dropped my
queen back to the a5 and now my opponent
played rook to f3 and here i played
bishop to e7 and you can see the
flexibility of this opening
any moment blackened castle not only on
king side but black can also go on queen
side and here my opponent plays knight
to c3 and this is what happened when you
play without any plan and the simple
repetition is bishop to c5 and gaining
the queen and the game
so this game illustrate a very simple
fundamental how you should play if you
opponent play knight to c3 supporting
that bishop
instead of knight to c3 at this point
the most logical reply from the white
will be capturing that knight so bishop
cross d7 and here i recommend that you
should capture with the king
and
do not afraid because your king is quite
safe and white cannot exploit it
immediately
so let's see some of my games from here
onward so my opponent responded with
knight to c3 and i played queen to c6
and here my opponent play queen to f3 so
attacking the bishop attacking the pawn
so
black response is pretty much forced
black has to play e6 and now my opponent
responded with queen to g3 so his idea
is very simple it's not only
pressurizing the c7 but it's also
pressurizing the g7 but right now g7 is
not a not a big threat because if the
bishop takes d7 then the rook can come
to the g8 and white will lose a piece so
that's why i calmly played rook to d8
and now i can do a artificial castle
with king to c8 and king goes to the b8
and black position is very very fun
let's see how the game progress so my
opponent responded here with knight to
e2 and i played king to c8 and after
knight to f4 i played rook to b8 so my
planning is very simple i want to play
the move g5 and hit the knight so my
opponent stop that with the move h4
and here i played bishop to e7 renewing
that threat and my opponent responded
with the rook to even which is a
slightly inaccuracy because now comes
the tactics which is
bishop takes h4 and after queen takes in
g5
my opponent is pointed with queen to g3
but after very simple knight takes queen
takes bishop to e4 i'm attacking the
juicy g2 square here my opponent made a
mistake he thought that he can cover
this g2 with the move f3
but after very simple rook to x8
that pawn is a goner so
in the game it happens like this so
after queen to h4
bishop takes f3 and g3 so stopping that
threat but after queen to c2
we don't need to go further from here we
can already see
black is quite fine and has a winning
position
so that was about bishop to f4 let's
consider the another move which is the
move f4 and here again we are going to
capture this with the d knight so knight
d cross
e5 please note white cannot capture this
knight with the d pawn otherwise queen
to c5
leads to
the bishop will be a goner so that's why
f cross e5 is pretty much force and
after f cross e5 i recommend that you
should play queen to g6
so attacking the c2
and not only that there are in some
lines this bishop can also
launch onto the h3 this game my opponent
responded with bishop to a4 protecting
the c2 and now i played the move e6 free
up the other bishop and after knight to
c3 bishop to e7
and bishop to e3
i played castle on the king side and
after knight to b5 attacking the c7 pawn
probably this is the weakest part in
this variation but this can be met very
very tactically so i played a very very
cunning move itself which is knight to
e5
and here my opponent fall into this trap
so my opponent captured this c7
afterwards i first of all play a knight
to c4 attacking the bishop so y doesn't
have time to capture this rook so bishop
drop backs to the f2 and now i hit this
knight one more time with rook to c8 and
after knight to b4
can you spot it yeah it's knight cross
b2
and white will lose a piece
so that is one tactical way if you open
and place knight to b4
and that is pretty much you need to know
when your opponent plays bishop to f4
and f4 this is
most of the
likely response you are going to face
you